hello everyone in the previous lecture
we had started our discussion on the
important topic of shear Center and in
that lecture we had first of all
motivated the discussion of shear centre
by referring back to the preliminary
considerations of bending in conjunction
with the possibility of twisting and
then we had discussed a few important
points which was related to the physical
considerations associated with shear
Center at the very end of that lecture
we had also mentioned that for the
actual derivation of the formula that we
need to use to find out the shear Center
one important assumption that we have to
make that have to make use of is that
the cross section will have to have will
have to be made up of very thin members
now in addition to that what we'll also
need is that the cross sections will
have to be offer of an open nature so
the the cross sections that will be
considering will be thin walled open
sections and as I had mentioned in the
previous lecture and this has direct
importance immediate relevance for
structural mechanics because many of the
cross sections like the Z section the L
section the T section the I Section
they're all exactly like that they are
thin walled and they also have they have
an open structural form so because we
want to have a general derivation of the
formula what we'll do is instead of
considering each individual case we will
consider a general thin walled open
section in this lecture so the kind of
beam that we are going to consider is
we'll have sheep somewhat like this
so I'd like to mention that this beam
has a thin-walled
open section meaning that this
particular thickness here it is it's
very small this thickness is very small
and because this end is not joined to
this end unlike for example and an
annular circular cross-section so
because this is not joined to this this
is an opened an open section what will
also consider to concretize our ideas is
that this beam just like in the previous
lecture would be would be attached or or
fixed to a wall here at this left end so
it'll be something like this
we will set up our coordinate access in
this fashion
so this will be our x-axis
this will be our y-axis and
this will be our said access now a word
of note about the x-axis in general it
is not necessary for our x axis to pass
through the centroid so for most of the
discussion that you would be having it
is not at all necessary that the x axis
passes through the centroid of this
cross-section but it just so happens
that near the end of this derivation
we'd be using the formula for the
bending stresses that we had developed
in during our discussions of unsymmetric
bending and please remember that there
we had actually considered the y axis
and the z axis to be centroidal axis and
if the y axis and the z axis are
centroidal axis when we are using the
formula for the bending stresses so it
necessarily follows that if we have to
again use the formula for the bending
stress or anything that has to do with
the mathematical derivation of the
unsymmetrical bending then it is also
necessary that the XS is x axis has to
pass through the centroid so you have to
remember that but for most of the
discussion we don't require the x axis
to be the centroidal axis okay now what
we'll do is we'll apply a load we will
apply a load like this
please note that this load this would
this load is in the form of a transverse
force and the line of action of this
transverse force is situated at a
distance of at a distance which will be
denoted by the letter e from the x-axis
so what I mean to say is that this
distance
that'll be e now because we want to
develop this entire mathematical
derivation for the shear Center what we
are going to say is that this force this
externally applied transverse force is
going to pass through the shear Center
so the shear Center will lie somewhere
on on this line of action and only when
that happens we can rest assured that
that this distance e will tell us will
give us an estimate of of where the
shear Center is located
now one may think immediately that we
are only considering a transverse force
which is parallel to the y axis
but you please note that there is no
restriction about this about the choice
of this y axis in the z axis other than
the fact that for the requirements of
our derivation they have to pass through
the centroid so if for example if we
have a force which is which is not
oriented in this fashion rather may be
somewhat oblique like this then there is
nothing stopping us from taking a Y axis
which is parallel to that orientation so
that kind of an oblique orientation so
you can very well take the y axis to be
to be oblique like that and parallel to
this thing so whatever we derive here
will absolutely hold true okay now what
we are going to do is will be exactly
like the case of the general cross
section that we considered earlier so
what we did earlier so let's take a
quick look here we had taken a cut
section consider this kind of a cross
section which exposed this kind of a
cross section and then we considered the
the cut piece which came out in front of
that cutting plane so we considered this
piece and we considered the
if the transverse force is passing
through the shear Center then the net
torsional moment due to this transverse
force and that contributed by the
distribution of shear stresses here
would be equal to zero so the torsional
moment by from this would be balancing
the torsional moment of this if that
balance will be true only if this passes
through the shear Center and now in the
present case since we are already saying
that this passes through the shear
Center so if we take a cut section
somewhere here then and the distribution
of shear stress is there in the expose
surface there would be balancing the XI
and the torsional moment here okay
so let's draw the let's draw the cutting
plane here this drawing is going to get
a little bit cluttered but you'll have
to deal with it so
so let me draw this other line also be
touching here and ring all the way
around be having it here and
so let me clean that up a little bit
okay so that is the that is the section
which will be exposed by this by this
orange colored cutting plane now as we
had done earlier what you are going to
do is we are going to take out this cut
piece so what I will do very quickly is
to name the piece which is in front of
the cutting plane as one and the piece
which is behind it as two so this one
represents this entire piece which is in
front of the cutting plane and the two
represents whatever is behind it and we
are going to consider this cut piece one
okay
so let's let's go to the new page and
draw that again very quickly so so we
have a
so this is our cut piece one
and
this
this hashed portion
that will represent the section over
which we are going to have the
distribution of shear stresses that is
pertinent to our discussion
okay let us not forget that we have our
transverse force acting like this all
right so I repeat again that it is the
distribution of shear stresses which is
present over this hatched part which
will contribute to a torsional moment
which will exactly balance the torsional
moment that is contributed by this
transverse externally applied force when
we take the moment about the axis and
that axis would be this x axis
okay so let me make that very clear here
that we are still considering this as
our distance e now let us remind
ourselves that the whole motivation of
considering such a special kind of cross
section namely a thin walled open cross
section was to make the the
determination of the shear stresses
relatively easier and the easy part here
has to actually do with with the
thinness primarily with the thinness of
this section because you understand that
because this is such a thin thin section
there would not be any appreciable
distribution or variation of shear
stresses across this thickness so so
across this thickness or all across this
thickness there would not be any
appreciable variation of the shear
stresses okay now what we are going to
do enacted to actually obtain the sum
expression of the shear stress is we are
going to consider a little element cut
out from cut out in turn from this cut
piece so the little piece that we are
going to consider would be something
like this so
so this is the piece marked out by the
white border that we are going to
consider so so if we if we isolate this
piece out it is going to look somewhat
like this
okay now what we are going to do is
consider another coordinate axis which
would be fitted along with or along the
along this cross section so what I mean
to say is that I want to set up a curved
access switches like this so this would
be represented by s please note that my
X is still oriented like this my y and z
axis are very much like this but they
are no longer under consideration now I
need to simplify the consideration of
this picture here a little bit and for
that I will change the way that I am
viewing this and this is a crucial step
and this will considerably simplify our
subsequent discussion so what I'm so
what I'm imagining is that I am looking
down I am I'm looking down
so I'll draw an eye here just like our
high school science books so this is our
eye and we're looking down so okay so
this is is an eye this is the okay so
we're looking down on this so so if we
look down on this what will it look like
this this little stress element that I
have drawn here what is it going to look
like well let's see
so from here I'm going to obtain this
please note that this is a top-down view
note here that the s axis is it is in
this direction and the X is in this
direction now let us not forget that our
primary objective here is to find out
the distribution of stresses on this
part here so in this diagram that
corresponds to this little part here
and
and that
edge it corresponds to this edge so I
repeat this edge here in this diagram it
corresponds to this edge here and of
course this edge the stoppage along
which the S is oriented that is this
edge alright now now because our primary
objective is to find out the
distribution of the shear stresses let
us go back to our ideas of undergraduate
mechanics and try to depict the
distribution of the of the stresses over
all these edges so what we are going to
do is to keep this picture relevant like
immediately relevant for our image for
our subsequent derivation we are going
to consider only those stress components
on this stress element which are
oriented along the X direction I repeat
we are only going to depict those stress
[Music]
stress components which are oriented
along the x axis so you understand that
this will be Sigma xx
these two vertical shear stress
components will will be related to the
Sigma SX so
but this one will be Sigma xx plus then
Sigma xx del X Delta X so note that what
we are doing here is we are considering
that this length is Delta X consequently
if we go back to the previous diagram
here
this length is Delta X
and you also note that this distance is
or this length is Delta s consequently
just like we have depicted the Sigma xx
through an increment of del Sigma xx del
X Delta X here we are going to represent
this vertical stress shear stress
component through Sigma SX plus
del Sigma sx del s because now we are
moving along the s direction times Delta
s so please note what is the underlying
idea here why are we doing all this we
are doing all this because our ultimate
aim is to find out an expression for
Sigma s X so we can do that if we can
express somehow the Sigma s X in terms
of the Sigma xx because in our previous
lectures we have already developed
expressions for Sigma xx under a general
case of unsymmetrical bending so even if
we have a very general cross section we
can in a very general kind of loading we
know how to write down the expression
for Sigma xx in terms of the given
moments which is the externally applied
load and if you can do that and somehow
we can relate the Sigma s X to the Sigma
xx then our job is the first step of our
job in it was finding the shear centre
is done and this is mind you the most
complicated step of actually finding out
the Sigma s X ok with that idea what we
can immediately do is to write down the
force equilibrium along the X direction
before we proceed it is extremely
important to note that if we if we
consider if we considered this diagram
to be like a free body diagram for this
stress element and when I say free body
diagram I basically mean that each of
these stress components would be
multiplied by their by their
corresponding cross sections so in that
case if we were to consider those
corresponding forces then this diagram
in terms of a free body diagram is
certainly not a complete free body
diagram so let me write that down
this is not a complete free body diagram
because you note that we have only
depicted the stress components along the
x direction because that is what we are
going to do we are going to - right we
are going to write down the force
equilibrium equation along the x
direction
but in reality there would be other
stress components along these various
edges we are not just we just not
depicting them so what we are going to
do is we are going to consider all of
these stress components multiplied by
them by the other corresponding areas to
obtain the forces and then set them
equal to zero so the summation of them
to be equal to zero so
so for force equilibrium
along X direction
now idealist is not the most convenient
configuration here to switch between the
previous page and the present page but I
am limited by space here so sorry about
that so the first thing that we are
going to consider is is this one the
Sigma xx over this face so you
understand that this face has a
thickness of T you note that this face
again is corresponding to this one which
has a thickness of T and it has a length
of Delta s so
Sigma X X times T times Delta s with a
minus sign in front because we are
taking the force equilibrium along the x
direction meaning the positive
x-direction and this this thing is you
note here is oriented along the negative
x direction so the next thing that we
are going to write is the contribution
of contribution to the force due to this
and that will be plus because it is
oriented along the positive x direction
Sigma xx plus del Sigma X sorry del
Sigma xx del X Delta x times T Delta s
and next considering
next considering this stress component
the shear stress component Sigma s X
what will obtain is minus Sigma s X
times T times Delta X the minus sign is
coming because if we just quickly refer
back to the previous page you see that
the Sigma s X is oriented this Sigma s X
is oriented along the negative x
direction next considering this
contribution which is which you note is
oriented along the positive x direction
will have
Sigma SX plus del Sigma s X del s Delta
s this whole thing times
T into Delta X and this entire thing has
to be equal to zero because the stress
element is understood to be in static
equilibrium now when we are writing this
you note one important thing we are
assuming that the thickness T is not
vary along the s direction so what I
mean to say is that if you move along
this in general the T can vary if it
varies then what we have to do is we
have to take this contribution of T
inside here with the Sigma s X because
you understand that if T varies with s
then it will be sitting inside this del
Delta the derivative with respect to s
but here we are not considering that
extra complication we are just going to
write it lock write it out like this
so from this what we can obtain is that
okay
now see as far as our our our goal of
expressing the Sigma SX the Sigma SX in
terms of the Sigma xx is concerned which
is which we understand to be something
that we know we are almost done
so how can you actually find it out so
what we'll do is we'll transpose the
Sigma xx term to the right hand side and
we will integrate so you understand that
this T cancels and we are going to
transpose this to the right hand side
and then we will integrate both sides
with respect to s so what that will give
us is Sigma s X is equal to minus
integration del Sigma xx del X
d s now you see what we have written
here is far from complete because it is
absolutely possible to write this in
form in the form of and this thing in
the form of an indefinite integration
but if we do that
what you are basically doing is as we
have written it here we are missing a
constant of integration because on the
left hand side we have integrated with
respect to s and we have gotten rid of
of this derivative but on the right hand
side we are doing this we are getting
this but when you when you do this kind
of an indefinite integration we are
actually left with a constant of
integration so if you don't write that
it is going to be wrong but what we can
do alternatively is we can consider this
integration to be done from a from the
point s equal to 0 to the point s equal
to s I repeat we can consider that we
are doing this integration from s equal
to 0 so let me write that down
we are doing the integration from 0 to
the generic point s now if we do this
you have to understand that what we are
basically doing here is so I have to
reduce this left hand side and rewrite
that again properly like this we have
obtained the sigma x sx
at the genetic point s minus the sigma s
x at 0 alright so what's going on here
you see we can just quickly refer back
to to this diagram here
you see we are starting our s access
like this which means the starting point
is somewhere here this is one end of the
open walled cross section so this is the
part where s is equal to zero so this is
where s is equal to zero here now you
note that we are writing the expression
for the Sigma s X so correspondingly
this is also s equal to 0 and we are
proceeding like this the whatever we
have obtained here like Sigma s X
evaluated at 0 basically means the value
of the Sigma s X which is present here
but that is an open is an open section
is an open end and because that is an
open end you note that that value has to
be equal to 0 there so
see if we go back to the
to our derivation here what we are going
to obtain is that this term is going to
be equal to zero
and what we'll be left with is just the
expression for Sigma SX and we are not
going to write this vertical line with a
subscript s to denote that this is Sigma
s X evaluated at any s rather we'll just
keep it simply like this with the
understanding that this is evaluated
that the left hand side this term is
evaluated some generic s and the right
hand term will be exactly remain as it
is
now because we have written all of these
things especially that Sigma s X is
equal to zero and we if we go back to
the previous page we'll see that we have
isolated our our little stress element
from here and we have said that this
Sigma s X is equal to zero but you know
that if that Sigma s X is equal to zero
say that Sigma X is equal to zero then
then why are we not writing this this
Sigma s X is equal to zero because you
note that the edge that we are that we
are depicting here so this edge
this edge is this edge I repeat this
edge is this edge so we should have
written this Sigma Essex to be equal to
zero but you but you know that this
stress element has been drawn in this
fashion only as special case what
ideally we should have done is to
consider a stress element which was not
starting from this open end rather it
was starting from somewhere in the
middle in that case this s would not
have been at s equal to zero so it is
important to have this much
understanding when you are looking at
this derivation it is also important to
note that if we are actually writing our
Sigma s s s X for this particular edge
does it really answer our our objective
of finding out the stress distribution
here because I have already mentioned
that we are kind of happy that we have
found out Sigma s X in terms of the
Sigma X X in terms of the integration
but does it really answer our objective
the answer is yes it does because you
note that here on this edge at s equal
to zero this one this is our Sigma s X
but on this hatched part
that would be actually Sigma X s so if
we were to actually write down let me
write write the down in red just to just
as a special case
so our
this red colored thing stress component
would be Sigma X s but we note that
Sigma X s will be equal to Sigma s X and
it is based on this based on this fact
that we are kind of happy that we have
found out this expression for Sigma s X
okay so this is like an indirect way of
being happy so since we have managed to
find out an expression for Sigma s X we
have also managed to find out an
expression for Sigma xx is exactly the
same thing but that entire thing is now
expressed in terms of Sigma xx so our
next job will be to find out how to
express this Sigma xx or how to find out
this Sigma s X in terms of the given
load so to express the Sigma xx in terms
of the given load what we will do is we
will refer back to the formula that we
had derived in the previous during our
previous lectures on unsymmetrical
bending with a special consideration and
that the kind of loading that we have
will only contribute to MZ so going to
the next page will Express the Sigma xx
so we note that that you already know
this the Sigma xx will be MZ y iy - said
I wiser
/ iy z square minus iy I said please
note that this formula is only a part of
the general formula for Sigma xx that we
had derived in the chapter on
unsymmetrical bending and I will provide
the link for that lecture now down below
another important point is that here we
have very much the expression for iy z
present because even though the y axis
and the z axis are passing through the
centroid they are not necessarily the
the principal axis so it is very much
possible that I wise it is not equal to
0 what this formula is not showing is
the contribution from my because the
kind of loading that we have considered
and that is not going to contribute to
the my ok so if we go back to the
previous page we see that now we don't
require the Sigma xx directly rather we
need the derivative of Sigma xx with
respect to X here so referring to this
particular part so what we really need
is this thing therefore Sigma xx
derived with respect to X is going to
give me all these things will remain as
it is
but the MZ that will have a derivative
with respect to X okay but we know from
our previous studies that the shear
force will be related to the bending
moment through this formula so that if
we quickly refer to the previous page
then the Sigma SX will ultimately be
expressed in terms of the shear force so
if we just substitute the expression for
Sigma for the del Sigma xx del X what we
are going to obtain is
Sigma s X is equal to minus 0 to s del
Sigma xx del X D s
so that is going to be equal to
integration 0 to s V why you note that
this minus this minus and this minus
will cancel each other and ultimately I
will have this expression
okay
now note very quickly that the I why the
I've I said and the I said they are
characteristic they're like the
geometrical characteristics of the
entire cross-section and they're like
constants for a put for any given
cross-section so it really does not it
is not necessary for us to keep them
within this integration with respect
integration from 0 to s furthermore at a
particular location along the
longitudinal axis of the beam the V Y is
having a particular value it is not
changing its value along the
cross-section so what I mean to say is
if we go back to this diagram the V Y
will be as a result of the entire
distribution of shear stresses here in
the vertical direction so if we are
considering a particular length from
this end so if you consider this
particular length so this the the V Y
there the shear force along the vertical
direction that will be a given constant
in fact for this particular problem
along the entire length the V Y will be
a constant and that will be equal to the
value that will be equal in magnitude to
this externally applied force if we have
a more complicated distribution of
transverse forces then the shear force
distribution will also change along the
length but we understand that and most
importantly that if we keep on changing
the value of s from zero to any generic
s the value of the shear force is not
going to change so that is also going to
going to come out of the integration
with respect to s so so let's recap V Y
can come out of the integration the I Y
can come out of the integration the I
wise it can come of the
out of the integration the eyes it can
come out of the integration so you see
the entire denominator here can come out
of the integration this part can this
one and this one individually can what
cannot come out of the integration is
this y&z so what can you do about it
well we can kind of simplify this
formula a little bit so what we'll do is
we'll go to the next page and try to
take out the things which we can out of
this integration
okay so just to repeat what we had
written earlier so Sigma s X is equal to
V y y i y- z iy z / iy z square minus iy
i said d s integration from 0 to s and
that'll be equal to v y divided by I Y Z
square minus I Y I said
so I why comes out but the why stays
inside integration from zero to S
- I y'see integration from 0 to s Z D s
so what have we gained by doing this
well you see written like this it is not
of much use to us but if we do a little
trick of multiplying this integrations
by the by the thickness then we can get
something really useful so what I'm
saying is in each of these integrations
instead of just the DS which depicts the
length along along the cross section
along the thin walled cross sections
suppose we multiply this DS by the
thickness then the tds would be
representing an elemental area of the
cross section similarly if we multiply
this DS by T then we'll be representing
an elemental area so what I mean by the
elemental area will be clear if I refer
back to this picture so you understand
that
this is d s this part is d s the length
of this is D s but multiplied by the
thickness multiplied by the thickness
across this so that is steel that
becomes the eighth in the elemental area
so that's what I mean so if I carry out
that step I have to note that since I'm
multiplying throughout by T I also have
to divide throughout by T so
what I have is this thing
so maybe I can
right that in a different fashion
so this is better why TDS is the same
thing but I like this better
this is I've I said integration 0 to s Z
TDs ok so now the last thing that we
have to note is is interesting the
benefit of having written this these
integrations in terms of the elemental
area is that we can immediately note
that because this TDS is the elemental
area multiplied by the y this basically
represents the first moment of area
about the z axis this one represents so
this since this is the elemental area
and Z is the distance from the y-axis so
this represents the first moment of area
about the y axis so if we represent the
first moments of area by the capital
little letter Q then what we'll have is
V Y
sorry
that's why I said whole thing multiplied
by t in the denominator and in the
numerator I have iy x qz which is the
first moment of area about the z axis
minus I Y Z multiplied by the first
moment of area about the Y axis and one
last important thing is that for this
particular case that we are considering
the V Y is nothing but minus of P so you
see what we have achieved we have
managed to write our expression for the
Sigma SX which again we note is equal to
the Sigma xx XS in terms of the given
load which is P so let me write that
down by going back to the page here so
this is P the magnitude of this
externally applied force is P
so we have managed to write the shear
stress in terms of P in terms of the
second moments of area in terms of the
thickness in terms of the second moment
of area second moment of area and here
the first moments of area so you see
overall we have managed to write down
the expression of the shear stresses in
terms of the given load now does this
mean that because we are developing a
way to find out the shear Center does it
depend on the on the transverse on the
given transverse load certainly not
because we see because you see although
we have done a lot of we have we have
gone through a lot of steps but in terms
of in terms of of the of the means to
find out the shear Center we have only
we have only done half the other half
the next important step is to actually
make an account of the shears or the the
contribution from this shear stress to
the torsional moment and to equate that
to the externally applied torsional
moment so you note that if we take the
torsional moment of this Sigma excess
contribution about any axis this P will
is going to be present there and if I
balance this against the torsional
moment which is actually contributed by
the by the given applied load which is P
itself so from that balance this P is
going to cancel out with that P so the
idea is like this so if you go to the
next page so it may seem a little bit
daunting that after doing so much we
have only done half but in reality you
have done a lot so
so in an actual problem
what we have to do is
calculate
the torsional moment contributed
by Sigma X X which is equal to Sigma s X
and for which we have already found out
the expression
and equate it to the torsional moment
contributed by the given transverse load
II so so on the left-hand side on the
left-hand side we'll have the
contribution from Sigma X s which is
equal to Sigma s X and this thing will
involve the P because as we have seen in
the previous page the expression for
Sigma s X it involves this P and on the
right hand side what we are going to
have is the torsional moment contributed
by the given transverse load and what is
that value so if we look back at this
diagram we can clearly see that the
torsional moment which is contributed by
the P about this x axis is nothing but P
times E
so this right hand side is nothing but P
times e so you see on the left hand side
we have will have some expression which
will involve the P in the numerator and
on the right hand side also we'll have
some expression which will have P in the
numerator so this P on the right hand
side and this P on the left hand side
will cancel each other and ultimately we
will have an expression for this e so as
we had mentioned earlier this e will be
depicting the distance of the shear
Center from the x axis and this this
location of the shear Center is very
much going to be independent from the
from the given transverse load which is
P okay so let's write that down
so what we have written here is that
ultimately P will cancel from both LHS
and RHS and the e the location of the
shear Center will be independent of P
okay so with this way we have kind of
finished the theory part for for the
shear Center the ideas will be clear
when you do some problems of finding the
shear Center
okay thank you